Faux ribbing is a tuck stitch pattern
that resembles ribbing on the knit side.
It's not stretchy like ribbing, it just
mimics the texture of 2x1 ribbing.
I'm showing the stitch pattern on a manual
machine using the hold setting. But it can
also be worked on an automatic patterning
machine with this stitch
pattern and the tuck setting.
I've started my stitch pattern and you can
see that these needles have tucked and
there are strands over the held needles.
Now take the flat edge of your needle
pusher and push those needles
back into middle position.
Use the 2x2 needle pusher again and
push the opposite needles to hold.
Make sure you are not
holding the edge stitches.
Knit across and notice the
strands now over those needles.
Repeat this for the pattern
hold sets of two needles, knit across,
alternate the sets of needles and tuck.
Making sure you aren't
tucking the end needles.
Remember this is tuck and tuck
requires more weight than stockinette.
Be sure to watch your knitting to make
sure that the stitches are
knitting off correctly.
I encourage you to to give
this one a try for yourself.
It's a little hard to see in the photos
but it has great texture and the purl side
is quite attractive and textured as well.
I hope you'll give it a try.